[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
einen schönen sonntagabend mit den
wichtigsten nachrichten gute von olympia
aus china gleich mit kristin otto gold
im eiskanal guten abend und das haben
wir heute für sie vorbereitet
hoher erwartungsdruck bundeskanzler
scholz reist zum antrittsbesuch nach
washington dort wird der deutsche
russland kurs sehr kritisch gesehen
historisches jubiläum seit 70 jahren des
krieges die zweite auf dem britischen
thron so lange wie niemand zuvor
und olympiasieg in peking rot johannes
ludwig holt die erste goldmedaille für
deutschland
[Musik]
bundeskanzler scholz der heute zum
antrittsbesuch in die usa reist steht
unter druck in der ukraine krise wird er
von kritikern als zu zögerlich zu leise
zu unklar wahrgenommen auch in
washington ist man teilweise irritiert
über die deutsche position zu
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine oder
möglichen sanktionen gegen russland
insofern große erwartungen an scholz
wenn er morgen us präsident biden trifft
christiane hübsche
so wir haben ein kleines technisches
problem und machen einfach mit dem
nächsten thema weiter und der nächsten
meldung politisch motivierte
kriminalität gegen politiker hat
offenbar drastisch zugenommen das
berichtet das handelsblatt und beruft
sich dabei auf zahlen des
bundeskriminalamtes demnach wurden
letztes jahr fast viereinhalb tausend
straftaten gegen amts und mandatsträger
registriert fast dreimal so viele wie
2017 ein grund für den anstieg sei eine
zunehmende radikalisierung in folge der
korona pandemie
wir schauen jetzt auf die aktuellen
corona zahlen binnen 24 stunden
registrierte das robert-koch-institut
133.000 173 neuinfektionen das sind 14
1203 mehr als vor einer woche außerdem
kamen innerhalb eines tages ein und 40
todesfälle hinzu die sieben tage
incidents liegt jetzt bei rund
trotz rekordzahlen und animiert von
ländern wie dänemark wird bei uns wieder
kontrovers über lockerungsmaßnahmen
diskutiert während die regierungspartei
fdp auflockerungen drängt mahnen die
anderen parteien zur zurückhaltung
unterschiedliche signale auch aus der
union mehr von jürgen kehl
hamburg st pauli das restaurant über
quell mit eigener brauerei ist kämpft
wie tausend andere mit den folgen der
pandemie jetzt hat es wieder zugemacht
kein umsatz kann er aussicht auf
schnelle änderung es herrscht frust in
der gastronomie es gibt andere länder
die haben fünftausender instanzen mit
fast normalen leben ich will nicht
ländervergleichen ich will es mir nicht
anmaßen aber es wirkt manchmal schon
doch sehr vorsichtig wie wir damit
umgehen die zahl der korona fälle steigt
und steigt allerdings hat sich die lage
auf den intensivstationen durch die
omikron welle bisher nicht
verschlechtert ein signal für einige mit
lockerungen zu beginnen hessen etwa
beendet morgen die 2g regelung beim
einkaufen der ruf nach einem
deutschlandweiten öffnungs fahrplan wird
lauter bayerns ministerpräsident sagt
der konsequente einsatz von fb zwei
masken erlaubt die rücknahme von kontakt
beschränkungen dazu muss der bund einen
stufenplan vorlegen
nrw-ministerpräsident wüst ist im zdf
zurückhaltende er verlangt aber auch an
den ausstiegsplan für alle damit die
menschen auch verstehen was hier
geschieht wenn es jedes land wieder
einzeln macht glaube ich lösen die
verwirrung aus und das wäre nicht gut
das gesundheitsministerium aber bremst
bisher habe man alte und vor erkrankte
gut schützen können die diskussion komme
zu früh von daher war nicht davor dass
wir schon lockern bevor wir überhaupt am
höhepunkt sind wenn wir den höhepunkt
überschritten haben und die maßnahmen
haben bis dahin gewirkt dann kann man
locker unter scheitelpunkt der
mikrowelle wird mitte des monats
erwartet wie auch die nächste bund
länder coroner runde schnelle
lockerungen sind dann wohl nicht zu
erwarten
ein ausführliches interview mit
nrw-ministerpräsident wüst gibt es im
heute journal wir holen jetzt den
beitrag
nachdem wir zu beginn spielen wollten
wohl also der bundeskanzler scholz reist
nach washington zum antrittsbesuch bei
us-präsident beiden und steht unter
druck mehr dazu jetzt von christiane
hübsche
olaf scholz auf dem weg zu seiner ersten
echten außenpolitischen bewährungsproben
in washington werden die morgen vom
bundeskanzler wissen wollen was tut ihr
deutschen wenn putin die ukraine
wirklich angreift aber auch im ard
interview kurz vor abflug wird scholz
nicht konkreter als zuvor
das werden sehr weitreichende sehr harte
sanktion sein falls das notwendig wird
obwohl ja gegenwärtig unser ganzes
bestreben darauf gerichtet ist zu
verhindern dass es dazu kommt dass
sanktionen
notwendig werden neue luftbilder sollen
zeigen dass putin mittlerweile an der
grenze zur ukraine 70 prozent des
militärs stationiert hat dass es für
einen großflächigen angriff auf das
nachbarland braucht und so kritisiert
cdu-chef märz für die opposition diese
reise kommt zu spät sie wäre schon vor
wochen notwendig gewesen jetzt wird die
reise wie der besuch eines bittstellers
sie kommt zum exakt richtigen zeitpunkt
man fährt da ja nicht einfach mal so hin
um einen kaffee zu trinken sondern es
geht ja darum echte harte wichtige
politik zu machen die in diesem fall
natürlich in einer sehr krisenhaften
situation stattfindet in der ukraine
trainieren derweil immer mehr zivilisten
den umgang mit der waffe um ihr land im
ernstfall zu verteidigen
waffenlieferungen aber lehnt deutschland
weiter ab lediglich könne man darüber
nachdenken mehr soldaten ins baltikum zu
schicken bestätigen heute
verteidigungsministerin lamprecht genau
wie scholz zuletzt gab es kritische
stimmen selbst aus der ampel regierung
ich glaube dass die kommunikation
schwierig war ich glaube dass die
amerikaner sich freuen dass der kanzler
kommt oder einiges was jetzt auch
vielleicht zu missverständnissen geführt
hat geregelt werden kann olaf scholz
umfragewerte waren zuletzt abgesagt mehr
sichtbarkeit mehr führungen werden von
ihm erwartet am abend landet er in
washington wo er morgen us präsident
biden trifft
70 jahre an der spitze des englischen
königshauses das ist ein rekord den
königin elisabeth der zweiten wohl
niemand streitig machen wird das
jubiläum begeht die queen er leise und
denkt dabei an ihren nachfolger prinz
charles und seine frau camilla
überraschend ließ die queen nämlich
mitteilen camilla wird sich königin
nennen dürfen wenn charles den thron
besteigt aus london andreas stamm
sie kennt nur einen weg den richtung
pflichterfüllung am vorabend ihres 70
thronjubiläums empfängt die queen gäste
auf schloss sandringham die humor wie
immer trocken die widmung auf der torte
falsch rum so der hinweis damit die
presse sie lesen können elisabeth
kommentar ich zähle hier nicht
sie hatte dieses funkeln in den augen
dann ihr sinn für humor sie wirkte
ein wenig fragil war sie aber welch
wunderbare humor der ist wirklich
herausragend
in einem statement zum jubiläum betont
die queen sie werde weiter ihrem volk
dienen was bekräftigt abdankung
ausgeschlossen und macht ihrem sohn
thronfolger charles das wohl größte
geschenk wenn er könig wird darf sich
seine frau queen carmela nennen was
lange umstritten war gilt camilla doch
als mitverantwortlich für das scheitern
von charles erster ehe mit dana
umgeben von ersten geschenken kleine
symbole dafür dass die queen die
relevanz der monarchie erhalten konnte
durch sieben jahrzehnte voller
veränderungen als ein die nation einen
des band
ist ein anker der stabilität in zeiten
von krieg und frieden gesellschaftlicher
ruhe und aufruhr und jüngst in der
pandemie pandemic der heutige tag bleibe
so elisabeth auch an diesem jubiläum
einer der trauer um ihren vater könig
georg den sechsten auch deshalb und in
der hoffnung auf gutes wetter mit mit
der großen feier bis juni gewartet
und wir machen jetzt mit olympia weiter
und dem ersten gold für deutschland ein
super triumph der mann der die gesamte
rote saison bestimmt hat rast auch im
olympischen eiskanal zu einzel-gold
johannes ludwig feiert mit 35 jahren
nach vier souveränen läufen zu recht den
größten erfolg seiner karriere
riesenjubel direkt nach dem zieleinlauf
des ersten deutschen olympiasiegers
dieser spiele johannes ludwig oberhof
rodelt inklusive bahnrekord zu gold der
stadt hervorragend der gesamtweltcup
sieger findet stets die perfekte linie
im eiskanal von young ging in allen vier
läufen zeigt der 35 jährige
bundespolizist keine schwäche
blitzsaubere sieg
im moment fühlt sich ganz gut an weil
sonst kommt der druck immer von vorne
hauptsächlich wurde und jetzt kommt der
druck von der schweren medaille aus dem
becken aber ich spaß beiseite ich bin
irgendwie ja ziemlich glücklich silber
geht an den österreicher wolfgang kindl
und bronze an dominik fischnaller aus
italien rekord weltmeister felix loch
kommt nach überstandener krone infektion
auf rang vier der mann des tages aber
heißt johannes ludwig
die deutschen skispringer kunden dagegen
die erwartungen nicht erfüllen sie
blieben in ihrem ersten wettbewerb von
der normalschanze ohne medaille als mit
favorit markus eisenbichler seinen
ersten sprung von der normalschanze in
jacko absolviert ist klar dass es nicht
der tag der deutschen skispringer werden
wird er landet bei 92 meter wird 31 der
kopf nicht mehr in den zweiten durchgang
der ebenfalls favorisierte karl geiger
wird mit seinem zweiten sprung am ende
15 tag besser macht es konstantin schmid
der im gesamtklassement den elften platz
belegt stephan leyhe wird
vierundzwanzigster
olympiasieger wird der japaner ryo
kobayashi mit diesem gold flug silber
geht überraschender den österreicher
manuel fettner und bronze holt der pole
dawid kubacki
und zum fußball debakel für borussia
dortmund der bvb unterlag leverkusen 25
und hat nun neun punkte rückstand auf
tabellenführer bayern münchen die bayer
elf rückt als dritter bis auf fünf
punkte heran und noch mal zu olympia wo
die alpine abfahrt der männer mehrmals
verschoben werden musste windböen bis zu
50 60 km/h viel zu gefährlich der wind
ein riesenthema und die kritik am
austragungsort in den bergen verstärkt
sich neuer versuch morgen früh um 5 uhr
live im zdf christin vielen dank auch
woanders beschwert man sich über das
wetter nicht bei uns in den allermeisten
gegnern war es heute größtenteils schwer
auszuhalten und so geht es weiter es
bleibt wechselhaft mit regen mit
schneeschauern an den alpen lässt der
schneefall allmählich nach temperaturen
1 bis 9 grad dazu ein starker
nordwestwind mit stürmischen böen
das heute journal mit bettina schausten
sehen sie um 21 uhr 45 schönen dank für
das interesse einen schönen sonntagabend